では始まります それで五つの精神的な病気のことをね
障害というかね 成長に障害になること
終わってから智慧という財産の説明に入ります
異常の五つは心の障害
心の汚れだと理解する仏弟子は
異常な欲などの五つの障害が心に入らないように努めるのです
この五つの障害 よく覚えてください
これ大変なものなんです
仏教では五蓋と言うんですね
いわゆる五つの蓋 すべての成長
すべての成功 一切の幸福に蓋をかけてます
それまた五枚もありますからね
これだけはあってはならないんです
この五枚の蓋がね なくなっちゃうと
もう心っていうのはどこまででも成長する
この物質 お金が欲しいとか
物質に依存することもなく
ものすごく無限に成長するんです
だから このサイキに教えたんだからといって
お釈迦様がこの何といいますか
欠陥の教えはしません
お釈迦様がこのサイキの人に教えたものでも
その人真面目に守ればどこまででも成長はするんです
そこはさすがの不思議なところなんです
ただ 日常生活の夢の話をして
この夢叶うためにこうしなさいということで
それだけではなくて どこまででも発展成長することを教えているんです
だから 五蓋っていうのは瞑想にも邪魔なんです
瞑想が上手するのは この五蓋
五つの障害がなくなった時なんです
いわゆる機能しない時なんです
だから我々にもこの五つは機能しないようにすることはできます
例えば異常な欲だけは
はい アウト さようならと
異常な怒りにはさようならと
たまたま誰かが変なことを言ったら怒ったっても
それは異常じゃないんですね
できればそれも控えておけば
異常な怒りにはならないんですね
それからもう昏睡睡眠状態でいない
いつでも活発でいる 寝ることはもう本当に体が疲れた時はその時間だけで寝ることにする
ずっと起きていて 活発に
もうもう眠くなってきたらでも何かをして眠気をもうもうなくすと
それは夜に預かっておくこと
寝ることはそういう風にこの入らないようにする
それから興奮状態 混沌した状態
それから後悔っていうのはまるっきりしないこと
いつでも前向きにあれやっておけばよかったっていうことは
もうものすごく猛毒やと思って
今やるべきことをやるぞと
それからまあ疑い疑いはなくすと
疑いなくすってことは
そんな頭がいいわけないでしょという考え方あるかもしれませんだけど
世の中のことはどうせ間違ってますから
疑っても構いません その代わり
ブッダの教えだけは絶対疑わないと
人ということを疑ってもいいんです
人は真理を語るわけじゃないんですし
真理を知っているわけでもない
だから政府が言うこと
お医者さんが言うこと
誰言うことでも もうもうそれなりに配慮して聞いてもいいんですけど
完全に信じる必要はないんです
しかし ブッダの教えだけはもう真理ですから
それには疑いを持たないだけで
その問題も解決 頭良くなります
もう奇跡的に良くなりますよ
はい それでアヤンウッチャティガハパティアディサコマハパンニョプトゥパンニョアパートダソパンニャーサンパンノ
この仏弟子は大智慧 広大智慧思慮がある智慧があるというのです
すごい簡単に解決しちゃったんです
智慧があるということは
誤解がないことなんです
そこでそんなもんじゃないんですよ
智慧っていうのは ものすごいものなんですけど
言ってもわからないでしょ
だからお釈迦様が五蓋だけあんたよく知ってるんだから
それだけ入らないようにしてくださいと
それだけでもあなたはすごい智慧があるんだよ
それがどこでも成長していくんだから
もうどんどん智慧が現れていくんです
だから誤解がなければ
あの五つの無知な人の道をなければ智慧っていうことです
異常な欲がなければ頭がいいでしょう
理性があるでしょう 異常な怒りがなければもう理性があるでしょうに
そういう五つだけでも智慧が現れたことにしているのです
期待は叶う この四つの財産
資本ですね 確信 道徳 施し
智慧がある人に 人は誰でも夢見る稀有な四つの願望が叶うのです
この 4つがあれば 信 サッダ
ブッダを信じることと
道徳 五戒守っていることと
それから施し 分かち合う性格と
それから智慧 智慧っていうのは誤解がないこと
頭しっかりしている それで OK だよと
叶いますよと 稀有な願望
金持ちになりたいということも
名誉を得たいということも
長生きしたいということも
死んでから天国に行きたいということも
こんなこと守れば天国しか行くところもないでしょう
またかえって 五戒守るとどこに行くんですかね
死んでから行くところがないんです
天国しか それぐらい確保しますよ
五戒さえ守っておけば
死後 天国っていうのはもうはっきり決まるんです
他のところはもう門前払いなんです
地獄に行こうとしたっても
もう向こうは追い出すんです
そういうことで 夢は全部叶いますと
幸福を過ごさせる業の力と
具体的に努力するという現実性という 2つのことで期待が叶うということです
だから ミクニのお釈迦様が言っていることが
人間というのは現実的に働かなくちゃいけないと
しかし 働いただけではね
金持ちになりませんよと
覚えておきなさいと もう一つ
精神的なエネルギーも必要ですよ
それは業 カルマですね
2つに合わせてあげているんです
業もどんどん良い業 善行為をして
して たくさん功徳を貯めておく
それからなまけず頑張ると
もう文句の文句のないように成功します
世の中 1個だけと思うんですよ
むちゃくちゃ仕事をする
頑張るんだけど 一向に金持ちになれない
だから 仕事してただけで金持ちになるわけじゃないんです
精神的な問題もある 逆に精神的には落ち着いて
欲がなくて もうきれいな心でいたっても頑張らないと １円も入ってこない
家に会計をかけて五戒守っていたってね
何もしないと守ってるんだからね
どうにもなりません 社会に入って守らなくちゃいけないんです
だから 2つ必要なんです
頑張ることと 頑張った分
収入が得るぐらいの恵みも欲しいんで必要なんです
いわゆるラッキーというかね
ラッキーパワー ラッキーパワーがもう得る方法を教えたんです
頑張っただけで 祈りをしただけではダメです
ということではい それで教典終わると言えます
あ いや まだセクションある